what is your name sir i am bill  butlicker  really that's your real name how dare  you  my family built this country by the way  be respectful dwight please oh yes  michael could you hold on one second  that's my other line  what no but i hello yeah  no i'm just on the phone with this  stupid salesman he's so dumb  probably just gonna keep him on the line  forever and not buy anything  okay it's up to you to change his mind  sorry that was a  family emergency oh no what's wrong you  know what that's private  boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr  butt licker as i was saying  we're having a limited a little bit  louder i'm hard of hearing he's sorry if  he's an old man  okay as i was saying right now we are  talking louder okay  our prices have never been low you have  to talk louder never been lower  louder son buttocker our prices have  never been lower  that is totally inappropriate